I want to painfully step through this one line of code here,
which in Dimple, binds our data to the SVG that we want to draw the chart in.
Replacing this line of code in dimple.js with the equivalent d3 statement,
we can see here that in d3 there's actually five functions we have to run.
While using d3's chainable syntax, we could write this all on one line.
I think it's much more clearer of what's happening when you write each new
function called on a separate line.
I wanted to step through each one of these function calls, and
then the web browsers chrome console.
I want to inspect what gets passed in and what gets returned from each.
As you can see here, I put a debugger before and
after the d3 code that binds data to our SVG object in circles.
And I also comped out adding the header title since we're not actually going to
be drawing the entire chart, but walking through only the data binding process.
In the last bit of code I've added are some diagrams visually explaining
the data binding process to the webpage itself as an image.
Opening up the Chrome debugger tools by going to the top right menu,
scrolling down to Tools then JavaScript Console.
We can see here the console threw an error since we
removed the dimple.js code that actually created the chart.
Let's refresh the page.
So our debugger touches before any of our chart code.
After reloading the page we can see here the first debugger statement caught.
What I'll be showing on the webpage itself are some diagrams I
created that visually explain what's happening with the d3 code here.
Before we call the .data function, all we have is SVG on the page and
the worldcup.tsv data file,
which has been loaded via AJAX using the d3 convenience function.
If we inspect our data variable, just like previously, it's a JavaScript array.
In this case with 836 elements,
each of which is an object with a bunch of fields.
Remember that the Chrome Developer Tools provided a convenience function
to print out a tabular representation of a data file such as this.